good morning millennials welcome back to
the morning toast it's hump day
hump day oh yeah it's hump day it is
wednesday so make sure to hump
someone you love i have theo here in
studio jackie has bruno back at home so
make sure you're evaluating your life
and acknowledging the space that you're
in and making sure that you have someone
that you love that you want to hump
every wednesday
100 um i have like a huge life update
for everyone
wow okay i am feeling so positive like
i'm a new
woman from yesterday what happened
nothing in particular yesterday was just
like a bad day for me like i didn't
sleep great and i woke up on the wrong
side of the bed and
i didn't i just i hated my outfit i felt
like so fat and i really wasn't feeling
good my throat was hurting me
24 hours later i like my outfit i slept
great last night even though i did have
like a nightmare
um i'm feeling a lot better i just and i
had a coffee this morning like that i
liked like from my house like a
starbucks cold brew with ice and half
and half like i love that yeah so i'm
just feeling i've been
up for like you know a good amount of
time the mask mandate restrictions have
been lifted here in new york like
it there's literally no reason not to
smile
though your heart is aching sorry i'm a
little hoarse
no i totally agree with you i'm so happy
that you've done this
180. we love to see a positive claudia
looking forward to all of her positive
takes she's so rare
you know positive claudia doesn't just
show up most days no so we need to
acknowledge the space that we are in now
surrounded by a positive claudia which
leaves space for me to be negative
yeah and that's kind of never really
like your thing what negativity no
you're actually like a
glass half full kind of gal oh my thanks
i mean i try and also like i've read
enough of our podcast reviews to know
that like
people really get pressed when we
complain a lot so i feel like we can
only have
one complainer honestly i think people
who i'm about to say something crazy
like we might need to take out of the
podcast
just think about it we're not taking it
out so think about it
i think that people who complain okay
people who complain
that we complain too much are
anti-semitic because that is like a
jewish trait it is in our blood and if
you don't like it like you need to check
your anti-semitism at the door
that's obviously a joke like please
don't cover me i just thought it was
funny no like as jews we do complain
yeah and honestly like that's actually a
great joke for like a comedy club i
should write that down
yeah it's not really like a podcast
friendly joke yeah but these days we do
have a lot to complain about and it has
nothing to do with being just jewish and
complaining but not today
there's a lot of joyousness in the air
it's 75 degrees it's sunny we have an
amazing show
not only is it wednesday which is like
always a great day because it's hump day
energy
we have deer toasters our advice segment
but we also have an interview at the end
of today's episode if you're looking at
the podcast you can just keep listening
if you're watching on youtube there's a
separate video we have remy bader
from tiktok she is the realistic try on
realistic
try and try on haul queen of tick tock
she was so funny she was so real
um and i think you guys are really gonna
like the interview so that's at the end
of today's episode
as a podcast and just our next video on
youtube she was great and so many people
requested her so
i think it's it's just a good day it is
a good day we do have a great show for
you today so we're going to get into it
we're going to take advantage of the
space that you're in
and deliver the news that you need to
know as we always do
we're just deliverers oh for everybody
who's wondering how my two a day went
yesterday oh yeah
it went really well like it was really
seamless i feel like by the second
workout i kind of had forgotten about
the first one i didn't really feel
fatigued
matt from the live method said it was my
best workout ever
and he's been saying that like every
workout now so i just feel like that
means i keep getting
better you don't know why why exercise
give you endorphins endorphin people
endorphins make you happy
happy people just don't kill their
husbands they just don't yeah
um that's why maybe i am going to kill
my husband because no idea
because i do two a day naps maybe that's
why yeah maybe that's why so
everything was good people were
wondering what i do with my hair when i
like exercise before the toast
i just don't wash it when i shower i
wound up i showered twice yesterday and
took one bath because of the
because of the two a day wow it's a
shower after each workout
and then i bathed before bed i don't
know why i like can't picture you in a
bath
picture it's it's something to see
something to see i just like can't
envision you getting into a tub
well you know what usually it happens
very slowly because i make the water too
hot
so i'm standing there waiting for it to
go [ __ ] worse like your feet are
burning when you put them in and i just
like i feel so stupid like hunched over
waiting to get in
so i just sort of like burned my whole
body yeah no thank you
well that's because you're inexperienced
no i mean sometimes
it's the right temperature but sometimes
it's lukewarm and i'm like i'd rather
just push myself does your
bath nozzle have temperatures on it no
otherwise it wouldn't be such a gamma
mine does and it's like actually like a
huge thing like the privilege of having
temperature
on your shower or bath nozzle is so
like it's just one of those underrated
things that like now that i have it i
don't know how if i ever move like how
i'm going to live without
it takes out all the guesswork and some
of us are just going in blind
yeah no you're literally going in blind
when it's like i know exactly like to a
t
fahrenheit what i'm getting into wow
yeah
that's beautiful yeah it is um i feel
like we should just dive in because
there's like so much to discuss
okay um yeah i don't think there's
anything else that i need to share
because it just was like a
a standard day nothing crazy i went to
dinner last night watched rahoney
oh i went to a comedy show last night
how was it was crazy like to see it
wasn't in a club new york comedy club is
doing like outdoor shows on this like
rooftop and flatiron it was so nice
and our friend kristen who we went to
nashville with her now husband they got
married in covid
did a set and it was so good and it was
just like what a different experience
like
to not only see comedy outside but like
i feel like in the past six months and
since things have started to reopen
i've just been doing like the same thing
over and over again like dinner you know
but it was like a new activity and it
was really fun a new sensation
so supportive comedians i tried to go
but i showed up at the wrong place yeah
and i
missed it that's so you that's so me
that's so jackie like literally arrived
only to realize i arrived at the wrong
place
right because you you went to the comedy
club and they're not doing it at the
time they were doing it at
yeah i guess that's that on that and
without further ado
do where are you by the way he is here
he's just he's off camera he's feeling
shy today
yeah he's just been feeling a little
insecure yeah you know taking time for
himself but without
after two breakfast takes he's just been
like really carrying that weight around
but that spirit of the two breakfast
tigs lives on can not be squandered or
not be broken
without further ado to do here are the
fastest stories that you do need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning
toast and today we're excited to be
sponsored by ipvanish
what is ipvanish a virtual private
network a vpn for short a vpn is a super
important tool that helps you safely
browse on the internet
you can use a vpn on your computer
tablet phone even things like your fire
stick when you're streaming media
when you use a vpn all your data becomes
encrypted what you're reading what
you're searching what you're watching
whatever it is that you're doing
and that's important because what you're
doing on the internet is absolutely
nobody else's business but yours
ipvanish helps you remain anonymous and
secure on the internet
and for listeners of the show ipvanish
is offering an incredible 65
off just 3.49 for the first month or
31.49 for the year here's everything you
get with ipvanish anonymous ip addresses
meaning your personal ip address cannot
be tracked
you can circumvent any online censorship
they have more than 1500 servers on 70
plus locations
and you can get protection from using
public wi-fi so go to ipvanish.com
toast to claim your 65 savings they have
plans starting at just 3.49
or 31.49 for the entire year
this is the time to sign up because with
our discount code and their current
promotional offerings
you can get a vpn for 65 off their usual
offering
ipvanish is the best of the best rated
4.7 out of five on trustpilot
so ipvanish.com toast to get that deal
and start protecting yourself
online love it okay first story
something that's been like
making the rounds shannon moekler
moabler
milackler no mochler i think yeah it's
one of those names i'll probably never
get right
is claiming that she caught travis
barker and kim kardashian having an
affair
shannon mclachler claims she once caught
travis barker a shadow mogler
having an affair with kim kardashian the
younger sister of his current girlfriend
kourtney kardashian
moekler said she divorced barker back
into the picture
she said that she divorced him because
of his tryst with kim
she said i divorced my ex because i saw
them i caught them having an affair the
model confirmed that she was referring
to kim
who met barker when she was working as
paris hilton's assistant in the early
2000s
a source close to kim told page six on
wednesday morning that there is zero
truth
to these claims so shanna is saying that
kim and travis hooked up and she caught
it and that's why they got a divorce and
kim's camp is saying like this there's
this didn't know there's no way
well there's what do we believe there's
a few things to unpack here one
the fact that travis barker and kim like
might have broken up his marriage and
two
the fact that courtney is now dating
travis no to me the only thing that
matters is that courtney is now jading
travis because like what kim did in the
early 2000s with
whomever i do believe it
is irrelevant to me you want to know why
because i feel like and and this is
people who like watch the kardashians
religiously and like feel like they know
kim they really know like she had this
like
image of being like a sex symbol and
that she had the sex tape and she had
this like
kind of raunchy reputation and she was
like actually nothing like that she was
like super shy and she
didn't drink like there's the this
perception of her but it's not really
who she is and i feel like
this is kind of just like feeding into
like what people think about kim but at
the end of the day like i don't think
kim would ever do this
kim is so family oriented like she's a
child of divorce like i don't know like
i just feel like i know kim and i know
that she wouldn't do this
yeah but there are like a lot of quotes
going around now from like various
interviews that travis had done at the
time about how he couldn't keep his eyes
off kim and like to me
nobody could but like i don't care about
chad travis and shanna's like marriage
whether or not kim broke it up like i
seriously
don't care i can't tell you why i just
am wondering like if courtney's
dating someone that her sister hooked up
with because like to me that's so
a no-no it's incest even 20 years later
incest
yeah i don't know it is 20 years let's
say they did let's just play devil's
advocate let's say they did
it's 20 years later and it really feels
like this is the love of courtney's life
and some people are saying that she's
pregnant because she put up this weird
ominous [ __ ] instagram post
pinkalicious like and christmas tree
like maybe she's due in december there
were all these different hints
i actually watched a tick tock that did
kind of convince me that she was
pregnant
whatever i don't believe it so let's say
for argument's sake that they did [ __ ]
but now it's 20 years later
courtney's head over heels in love with
travis travis's head over heels in love
with courtney like
i i actually think i can move past it
even though that's like a huge no-no if
you read my book you know it's like one
of our rules growing up like you don't
kiss the same boy as your sister
but i might be able to get past this one
i don't know
i don't know i just really hope it's not
true so i don't have to think about it
yeah and i'm sure eventually like say it
was true and i and i took the time like
i do think i can get past it also and
it's clear that they've gotten past it
if it is true i just like really hope
that it's not because like
that's a real bummer like and if travis
is the love of courtney's life it's just
like
always like he had sex with her sister
again it's like you couldn't just
like not do one thing 20 years ago
because you don't know how it impacts
your life 20 years from now also i do
think that these allegations or whatever
you want to call them
are coming out in an interesting time
because there's also a lot of drama with
alabama barker
who is travis and chana's daughter and
she's been like posting tick tocks
basically alleging that
her mom was absentee and all this kind
of
um crazy allegations so i just feel like
maybe that's an attempt to discredit
shanna i don't know there's just like a
lot to unpack from the alabama barker
shannon oakley travis barker korean
kardashian kim kardashian saga
and i'm kind of like living for it i'm
not gonna lie yeah i just
there's one side is saying this like
there's just such different
recollections of of what happened and
let's say they did [ __ ] kim's camp would
not be like yeah we did
no but like they might not they might
just ignore her because like
who is she no that's a great question
who is
this article says model oh
me too same um
so yeah that's just like an interesting
turn of events
that's a little incest news for everyone
are you ready for our next story which
is taking us back in time because i
really am
you are you look ready no i'm feeling so
positive and at peace
and i've never been more ready for
anything than i am for this next story
good i'd love to hear that i just feel
like i exuded such negative vibes
yesterday like i need to make up for it
okay yeah sure let's just try something
new yeah
misha barton is saying that bullying on
the oc set led to her exit she said i
just felt very unprotected okay so misha
barton spoke to enews i read this whole
article about how this writer at e news
like just wanted just thought like she
would email misha and like see what
happened there i mean she just opened up
the flood
just responded and shared her truth
before we start i just want to say like
i have so much love in my heart from
for misha barton like i think she's a
gem i loved her on the hills last season
loved and i just think she's kind of uh
kind of how people
talk about brittany and how like she's
like an example of what the media can do
and how they're so evil
i feel like misha barton is one of those
as well yeah i totally agree i wish she
was back on the hills i thought she was
a great character would have loved to
see
more from her i don't know why they they
turned like when they picked her up i
didn't know why they did that and when
they dropped her i didn't know why they
did that yeah no once he picked her up i
was like what and then i watched it i
was like oh this is an interesting gal
she's
young fabulous hollywood gal stories to
tell things to say
vengeances to avenge and then they just
dropped her off maybe she didn't want to
be it anymore but like i thought she was
great
i thought she was great too but so now
she's responding to emails about what
happened
on the set of the oc so all of this is
being communicated via email
um yes i believe so okay and maybe they
got on the phone but she
reached out to her via email just
because i guess she was up one night
wondering why misha was killed off the
oc which i actually relate to this
article
this writer question so she said there
were people on
spoiler alert right there were people on
that set that were very
mean to me it wasn't like the most ideal
environment for a young sensitive girl
who's also been thrust into stardom to
have to put up with
she said sometimes during season two
things got more difficult for her the
hours got longer and the producers
started evening out everybody's pay
after promoting her co-star rachel
bilson because i guess summer wasn't
meant to be a full-time cast member but
she was such a star in that first season
how could you not
she became one of the core four and i
guess they they took her paycheck from
something
like from everyone else's so did they
demote misha's
payment or they just brought they might
they might have just like demoted
everyone got it um she said in sort of
general bullying from some of the men on
the set that felt
kind of really shitty but you know i
also loved the show and i had to build
up my own walls and ways of getting
around dealing with that and the fame
that was thrust specifically at me
just dealing with like the amount of
invasion i was having in my personal
life i just felt very unprotected i
guess is the best way to put it
yeah so she said that the the
showrunners came to her and they were
like
they didn't force her off the show or
anything they were like we could let you
go in a way that's kind of mysterious
and have you come back
or we could end it finally and you can
go move on and do whatever you want i
guess she had like other offers coming
in because she's at the height of her
career she's like no i want to take all
these things that i haven't been able to
take
and i want to go and i think when she
filmed and when she made that choice she
had no idea that it was going to be like
the cultural thing that it was like
hallelujah marissa cooper like being
carried through the streets
yeah um and so she just made the choice
to like
move on with her career well i honestly
can't tell if that was the right
decision because it did become this
actual phenomenon like the way you just
think of one of the most iconic moments
in tv history it has to be in like the
top ten
but she didn't really have much of a
career after that so it's like
which would you take the iconic moment
or the longevity i think the longevity
but in hindsight like
you know she and a lot of people do this
i think like it's probably frustrating
right you're the peak of your career but
you're stuck to this thing so you can't
take other opportunities but maybe you
choose the wrong opportunities and then
it's all downhill from there i think
that a lot about the kids from riverdale
how they became
so famous so fast and they literally
work every single day
365 in canada like they're so limited in
what they can do outside of the show
that they grew huge followings the show
became huge and then the show just kind
of dwindled and like
i just don't think of them they're super
famous but i don't think of them as like
the megastars that they were for like
that one year and they couldn't really
do much after that
well i just feel like they're still
doing stuff and i feel but i also feel
like they make weird choices like
madeleine in that movie f the prom that
was like so terrible
i just think they're very limited in
what they can do contractually not only
timelines because they only get like a
few months off but like and then also
like
i'm sure your contract is like you can't
do a tv show with abc you know what i
mean like
they're limited in what they can
actually accept and then timing of it
all i feel like cami does the best job
me too because she was in that spooky
movie that was on netflix
um that was like during quarantine um
what was the premise it was like it was
like a horror movie yeah she was in palm
springs which like was a
hit a mainstream success let me look at
i agree with you i do think that she
does the best job of balancing riverdale
and other work
but it's like a blessing and a curse to
become so famous on a tv show because
those tv shows especially the ones that
have like 22 episodes a season like
you don't get to work otherwise or
really even live yeah
i think the movie was called dangerous
lies which just goes it was like a
lifetime
type of movie but it was on netflix and
i think it did really well it was like
it was um what are those movies called
that are like
thrillers coming up the stairs you know
mystery things were scary
like a scary movie sure got it i think
i'm curious to know what the word you're
looking for is i don't know maybe spooky
spooky thriller thriller let's click on
the movie let's see how it describes
itself
it's probably a scary movie that's like
a genre yeah
okay anyways i guess they were dangerous
lies so it's definitely was scary
because it was so dangerous
so yes i agree with you like marissa
cooper
it's a weird thing like you become so
famous you become like best friends with
your cast mates
and then it kind of like dwindles
because you're limited in what you can
do outside of the show and the show goes
on for a long time
i can't believe riverdale's still on the
air yeah and i feel like where rachel
wilson and adam already were dating in
real life yeah
that helps them a lot i'm sure that
helps like you feel like you have
someone in your corner and she probably
just felt out on her own
yes and i do also think that like
one of the weirdest things like that
i've ever experienced is the fact that
adam brody and rachel milson dated for
so long and then he got married to
leighton meester who's literally
facial filson and who like literally
comes from the same exact career like no
it's
it's not even that she's facial filson
it said seth cohen and blair waldorf
literally got married
no and also like summer summer roberts
and blair waldorf were like the same
type type of character and they have the
same a similar career
so i just think that's like the weird
and they look alike too so like when i
see pictures i'm like is that an old
picture with rachel wilson or chrome
picture with lightning meester yeah no
it's shocking and i think it's just
another interesting factoid that a lot
of people don't really
like remember is that leighton meester
was born in prison yeah
that's a crazy story and they like kind
of referenced that in country strong
because it was like you know child
stanton was hiding this huge secret
about her past
what was it that her parents were in
jail
exactly great movie if you haven't seen
it who hasn't seen it like
probably a lot of people and that's
what's wrong with the world like
everyone has everyone's going to have a
mandatory viewing i don't think
rob definitely has okay ready for our
next story little love
news a little love news that's brought
to you by bruce
very appropriate since i love bruce and
when you're in love you're gonna need a
[ __ ] bruce
yeah you are um this spring drift into a
dreamy state of mind and reset with the
froosh
new limited edition colorways inspired
by a dream like
surrealism so what is the bruce you guys
it is the best electric toothbrush
on the market we talk about it here all
the time so many toasters have gotten
them and it has really changed their
life
it is very very effective in cleaning
your teeth your gums helps with breath
but it's also really affordable a lot of
electric toothbrushes can cost over 200
which is like nuts um but not the brush
very affordable
it comes with six unique modes to
customize your brushing experience it
has a two minute timer so you make sure
to complete
completely clean your uh mouth in all
four quadrants of your mouth gums back
front up sound the battery life lasts
four weeks it comes with a magnetic
charging stand that's very sleek and
elegant so it's not very cluttery on
your counter
um it also comes with a subscription
program so you never forget to change
your brush head again
some people think that like if you have
an electric toothbrush you don't need to
like change but you do it's
not very sanitary and they'll keep you
on track you don't have to remember
they'll just every six months
ship you a new brush head a replacement
so you're never stuck using a worn down
brush head their electric toothbrush has
a modern aesthetically pleasing design
and it comes in trend driven seasonal
colors so it looks great on your
bathroom counter
these new colors are only available for
a limited time check them out it's like
big launch you know you want to get the
new one um get them before they're a
distant dream
get 15 off the toothbrush kit from bruce
and the refill plan when you use the
promo code toast at bruce.com
that's 15 off using code toast at
b-r-u-u-s-h
dot com love it okay our love news asap
rocky says girlfriend rihanna is the one
i saw this and i totally forgot that
they were dating but i'm like reminded
again and now i'm happy again
he said when you know you know the
rapper told gq for the magazine's june
july 2021 cover story a bit about his
romance with rihanna gushing that she is
the love of my life
my lady when asked what it feels like to
be in a relationship he said so much
better so much better when you got the
one
she amounts to probably like a million
of the other ones so true i think when
you know you know
she's the one he also shared his
thoughts on starting a family saying
that fatherhood is quote
in my destiny absolutely i think i'd be
an incredible
remarkably overall amazing dad i would
have a very fly
child there so true um this is the thing
like
brianna's just like that [ __ ] like
she's like the elizabeth taylor of our
generation like
how the most eligible men in the world
used to like buy elizabeth taylor like
the boats and the diamonds and just for
a chance
to be in her presence and that is
literally rihanna like
every [ __ ] eligible you know that
saudi prince billionaire
drake everyone who's [ __ ] obsessed
literally they just fawn over her and
she's like yes
she's fine i'll take the boat so it's
just like
it's hard to see someone living your
dream because i really for you know a
while really to think i was the
elizabeth taylor of our generation but
it's very clearly just snatched up so
quickly
i've never had time chance i never had
time to grow into it yeah but like i'm
real like i i just made that reference
in my mind and like it's true or
maybe like the marilyn monroe like yeah
yeah but they're it's the same
it's the same thing and that's right
evelyn hugo yes
that is rihanna yeah i totally agree i
think that's a great call and it's like
the least you can hope for is that when
someone possesses
this diamond of the season that they can
recognize that that's what they have and
and i think she's recognized no i think
that he's recognized yeah like that
she's a million of the other girls
yeah and i'm happy for them i think
they're a cute couple i don't think i've
ever seen a photo of them like together
here's a photo of them together but it's
um i don't know when it's from
that looks like literally like photoshop
together so far apart
but like because their hands on his
shoulder i know that it's real yeah but
it could still be photoshopped i guess
anything can happen
they're really cute i'm happy for them
and that's a really sweet article i love
when people like publicly gush about
their partners in interviews like
when tiffany haddish like went on and on
about common yeah but also when
people gush about like how much they
love being in a relationship you know i
just think it sets a nice example like
because they feel like sometimes being
in a relationship like isn't the coolest
thing
to do it's like you're whipped bro yay
exactly but no
such a lame thing to say no and like
until
yeah no two taste makers making like
relationships cool
making tastes making taste 100 but
that's also how i feel about like
justin bieber and haley like getting
married so young and i just think it
makes that like a cool thing to do
and really you could do whatever you
want with your life it's just always
like
i agree i know what you're saying i
agree you know it's nice
are you ready for our next story the
dear evan hansen trailer is here
and there's drama claudia told me
there's drama which is shocking i just
want to share my initial thoughts
because zach was watching it in the car
i watched the tent i watched you put on
your story so i watched 10 seconds of it
um enough to know that ben platt is
playing evan hansen yes
and i i overheard the trailer and i just
felt like they gave away the entire
movie okay i thought the same thing it
was like a 45 minute trailer like
literally i was like from start to
finish i've just seen the movie
no and there's like kind of like a big
kind of twist in the
play and like they like kind of ruined
it did you know what i'm talking about i
know like they literally had every song
in the trailer like the whole plot like
dear evan hansen connor cohn yeah like
connor like all the different highs and
lows of evidence i agree they gave too
much away
it was an experience i loved it because
i'm gonna see the movie and i feel like
i saw like a part of it
it was stunning like the music i love
ben platt i'm like
literally his number one fan i commented
on the trailer and he liked my comment
oh my god that is so
rewarding i'm so excited i forgot how
good the music was i'm gonna
um do a run today on the treadmill i'm
going to listen to that soundtrack
because like you will be found i had
chills just eavesdropping from the
trailer and pasek and paul my kings
yeah so it's the greatest showman guys
it's it's perfect but so but it's like
all this time when we were like
you know hyping up the greatest show and
we're like it's the dear evan hansen
guys like now finally
people understand like how good at that
and now they're the greatest showman
guys yeah
and there we're also the la la land guys
if you're into that sort of thing i
like i know it's not a personality trait
to think that la la land was the worst
movie ever but like i
fully believe that it is my personality
i think it says a lot about your
personality
yeah no it's just like i think maybe i
disliked it because everyone liked it so
much and i'm just like
so like not like other girls you're not
like other girls i don't know why but i
digress
so you didn't really know and i only
knew because i'm on broadway tick-tock
because like i literally watch videos of
jessica vosk singing as wicked like
every day
and so my algorithm gives me like
broadway news um there was some drama a
couple weeks ago with some guy
but everyone was like going on and on
about
ben platt being selected as evan hansen
and they thought it was problematic for
two reasons
one because he's 27 and i think the
character is supposed to be 16
or like 17 whatever like a high school
has ever mattered in hollywood
and the other thing is that like maybe
there were more eligible people to play
ben
uh to play evan hansen who have been on
broadway like there's this guy who's
currently evan hansen on broadway and
he's 19. so people thought
he might be more eligible but that ben
platt only got the role because his dad
who works in hollywood is the producer
of the movie okay so there's two issues
one
the age thing which i think is so
[ __ ] stupid like where was all this
energy when like
four 90 year olds were playing high
schoolers on pretty little liars like
nobody [ __ ] cares regina george was
26 like
who cares no literally nobody cares
we're gonna care now
also he originated that role and didn't
he like write this show
so he won the tony for it he worked with
pasek and paul like he was a part i
don't know if he wrote it but i know
that he was
involved from the origin like he was a
part of making it what it was he showed
he popularized it he won the tony for it
and honestly i'm sure there are a lot of
people who do it
amazing i haven't seen anyone besides
ben platt but like he is the barbra
streisand a funny girl you would never
make a funny girl movie and not put
barbra streisand you know he is evan
hansen when i saw the trailer
it sounded like his voice i was like oh
okay it's been pop but like if it wasn't
going to be planned pat
ben platt i was going to be disappointed
but it's also really crazy that like
evan hansen came out or pete like was at
the pinnacle like five or six years ago
and it's already a movie whereas like
wicked
still isn't a movie well there's a lot
of drama with the wicked movie oh share
the drama with me but also
i would hope i mean now it's probably
too late but if there ever was a wicked
movie like i want i would want it to be
a dinner mentality and kristin
with of course the people who
popularized the the show
yeah 100 what's the drama um
like so like five years ago they
announced a wicked movie we reported
this on the toast i don't know if you
remember
and then they gave like a launch date or
like a launch month and that launch
month was like a year ago so people were
like repopulating the tweet and being
like
the movie's supposed to come out this
month like what happened i do believe
it's like still in the works but i don't
think it's gonna be any time it doesn't
bode well who's in it
they don't say anything yet and honestly
like if they just got pasic and paul on
the job we would be fine
yeah well the music is written but i
think it should be dove cameron and
ariana grande
or no no i don't think so ariana grande
and
who were who we already had this
alphabet
i forget i don't know we already figured
this out
they don't need to be that young though
i guess they go to college right and
wicked
yeah she is university
um so yeah and then they do
the other thing people are impressed
about is the nepotism of it all and
honestly i think i've said this before
on the show like
i'm so unbothered by nepotism i'm like
so jealous of it because i have like the
opposite of nepotism like whatever that
is
i'm i'm happy for them like if you can
get it like do it like i would do it too
like we're all liars like oh my dad's
producing a movie wait let's play this
out
my dad's producing a movie of the play
that i starred and
if anything popular opportunistic in the
other way where it's like his dad only
got the producer
how qualified is his dad because his son
wrote the movie it's reverse
nepotism 100 i just like don't care
if anything you should have been angry
when this like one time show
writer got a show on broadway because
his dad was in the industry yeah like
that was the time to be angry
no but also i would be angry if he
wasn't so
qualified for the role like i think
there's i'm not gonna like out people
but i think there's a lot of people who
have gotten famous like based on their
parents
attributes and like they're not that
great or talented and i don't understand
the hype it's only the hype because
their parents are superstars
ben platt is not one of those people i
think he would have become a bigger
just as big as of a star if he didn't
have
the connections that he did yeah so
sometimes like the talent matches
and that's really all i care about ben
platt is going to be amazing in it
so everyone can just [ __ ] off yeah no
i'm really excited the broadway stands
though on tick tock are [ __ ] pressed
like there's real problems going on
laurel yeah are you ready for our fifth
and final story i think it's some news
that's gonna make you even happier than
you already
what is it it's a little fast food wars
news that's it
yes that's for you every time we talk
about fast food i have
i have it for lunch excuse me well now i
know what you can order next
okay burger king launches a new chicken
sandwich nationwide
called the chick king oh it's a good
name yep burger king's new chicken
sandwich is here and it's entering a
market that's more crowded than ever
the burger chain first announced its new
sandwich in february since then it's
been rolling out the sandwich i love
when sandwiches get rolled rolled out
they're like a little late like i feel
like there's been like a conversation
about where the best chicken sandwich is
from
for a while they have been but you know
what i'm happy for this news because
personally like
when we used to go when we were driving
and we would all want fast food like
last year
i would want to stop at burger king for
the um
what's it called mc plant no but but
thank you impossible burger
yeah but it was like they had a cute
name for it i thought
what is the impossible the whop
impossible whopper okay and
that but then we would go over to
mcdonald's for you so like now we can
all eat it yeah
we all know we need that burger king let
me tell you why okay first of all
because when i go to fast food
scratching my nose in case anyone she's
not picking your nose uh when i go to
fast food i get chicken nuggets
and i actually really don't like the
nuggets from burger king because they're
tenders not nuggets and i just prefer
nuggets
um so i'll still always go to mcdonald's
also because mcdonald's fries are so
supreme like
even the best fry from burger king
doesn't stand a chance against the worst
fragment from mcdonald's like there's
just no competition so
we'll still have to drive to both stores
okay also i don't really i love chicken
sandwiches but not at fast food places
there's just like so many better options
for me
whereas like okay like in a restaurant
i'll order like a grilled chicken
sandwich all right okay so never mind
i mean i'll try it for our mukbang that
we're never gonna film
never mind no no it's it's good just
take this story back no no don't
i love i love fast food news throw it in
the garbage okay my negativity's seeping
back out
if you're in the chicken sandwich
fan club you've got another one to try
another one this is nice i literally
love that remember like the time when
dj khaled blew up snapchat yeah but do
you also remember the time when like
kanye and kim announced they were having
another baby and mason disick said
another one no i don't remember that oh
my god it's so where did he say it i'm
keeping up
he's such and kanye was laughing so hard
oh my god gotta go back and find the
club yeah no
it's really cute um should we talk about
real housewives of new york which was
like so boring last night
yes we shall i thought it was
interesting i thought it was interesting
too because i felt conflicted because
i really feel like ramona singer lying
about donating her plasma which i think
we came to that conclusion i do think
like
for a second ramona thought that she did
donate plasma just when she got tested
because she's like
you know not that in tune with the
medical community but i think she's
known for a while that she didn't
actually donate it and let the lie
continue
so i think that's like really low and
like classless i think it's like one of
the worst things you can do
i don't know but but i think like
leah was really bothering me last night
she was just like being the police like
to everyone she was being like
the plasma police even though like she
was justified and just like wanting to
prove her point
she was just like being really harsh and
then she was being like the fosae police
she was just being like the policewoman
yeah i have
i feel very conflicted about it do is
there something that you need to say
before we get into it or can we get into
the recap i've been in it for like no
but you're holding your curds
oh no no no i'm just protective over my
curds sorry i was like have you not been
listening to me
no i'm just holding my curd sorry okay
keep keep your kurds
close and safe no keep your cards close
and your curds
closer okay okay yes i feel extremely
convicted over leah because generally
speaking like
i i really am here for her as a person
and i think
that she's such a great thinker
sometimes you know that's such a good
way to put it and
she and like really sometimes when she
goes for something i'm like yes yes yes
but with this ramona plasma stuff she
came for ramona so hard in the beginning
of covid
because she was going to florida and
then she like got covered
and i understand at the time that leah
felt like that was the right thing to do
but now it's like eight months since
then like in hindsight like
i i don't know why she's going so hard
again where
she could have looked back on it and
been like well ramona did have
antibodies and
she was like like she wasn't doing
anything so crazy but at the time
everything felt crazy but now in
hindsight it's like oh she was just in
florida and she had anybody yeah i don't
really feel like
ramona like traveling from new york to
florida is like a big deal but leah is
like still
harping on the like that ramona was like
irresponsible during coven because she
like posted her cooking thing on her
instagram
well so and like and her workout when
it's like flashback to the reunion and
leah's like going after ramona for
posting her workout
on her stories i'm like that's like not
a big deal
entire [ __ ] world did that so like
maybe in the moment you saw it and you
felt like it was tone deaf but that's
like
not something that i would bring up
again it's like something that she did
wrong because that's what the whole
world was doing
yeah so like that was sort of bothering
me i feel like what happened with ramona
is that she thought she donated the
plasma because
something was like taken from they took
her blood they took something from her
and she thought that that was plasma i
agree but i think she's known for a
while and i think when she told the
press that she donated plasma
she really thought that she did i agree
afterwards
she learned that that was not what
happened but leah is really trying to
embarrass her and make her look like a
terrible person as if she lied
intentionally whereas i think that when
she said it she wasn't lying
i agree with you completely ramona for a
while like i don't know why leah
like her and leah aren't beefing right
now so i don't know why leah feels like
she needs to embarrass her in front of
everyone and like
make her admit that she was wrong i
think that for a while ramona singer
went to bed every night like truly
believing she helped someone i believe
that i don't think she's a bad person
like i don't think she would
intentionally lie because that's like
[ __ ] up yeah i don't think that she
did that
and i i understand leah like wanting to
like make the point but like she went
so hard she was just being like a karen
and i'm like
chill and then it was just like that was
the energy she had throughout the whole
day like
honestly what she said to luanne i
thought she i think she did have good
intentions
but then leanne luanne was literally
like you're literally doing the same
thing with your mocktail like
and luanne was right yes i think i
understood what lee was
trying to say because it is like a
crutch for
luanne and eventually she'll have to
learn how to walk on her own
but i think like telling her about it
while she's doing it and like leaning on
her crutch like that's just not that
helpful but i i do feel like her
heart was in the right place and like
luanne did come to her and say like
we're in this together like i want to
lean on you and so
i think leah thought she was just being
a friend whereas everybody in the group
has been getting along she's staying at
ramona's house and she wants to bring
this thing up to make like ramona and
barristan look bad
in front of everyone eight months later
i i don't i
i wasn't supportive of it that's the
thing i i forgot they're all staying at
ramona's house and
say what you want about ramona but like
she is the host and she's doing like a
nice job and you just don't
like attack someone like that when
they're you're literally staying at
their house
yes and then also i'm not understanding
leah's
point of view with this heather stuff so
then i thought she was also being
policewoman when it's like what are we
going to say to heather when she gets
here what time did she get her what
should we say let me pull up the
articles she doesn't know
just in case you forgot or you missed
what she said here's what she said
getting the whole group riled up against
each other and by the way they didn't
even pull up anything that
heather had said about leah so leah's
getting mad on like luanne and sonia's
behalf when luanne and sonia seem to not
give a [ __ ] right and it seems like
whatever heather said about luanne like
not being authentic like we all
recognize that there's an old blue and a
new loo
like even the way that she has done a
complete 180 about how to address
herself
to a driver like yes so heather knew
luanne when she really was that like
inauthentic can't
talk to her countess ladies so like i
don't find that to be offensive
but saying she does hard drugs is mean
and also saying sonya's
she didn't think she said that the the
knight in saint
tom bar the pirates that there was drugs
maybe there was drugs and i we also i
think we said this last week that that
is like so far
in the past and luanne has been through
so much since then like sure
it's like not that cool but it's like
not recent enough
i might just be biased because i
actually like love heather yeah i like
her too i think she's a nice girl i
think she's a nice girl i think she's
like a good businesswoman i think i
think like her time on the show which
she left voluntarily which is very rare
i think she was like a good friend she
was like really good friends with carol
and kristen takeman like
i she didn't give me any reason not to
like her her hollows were a little
annoying but
other than that there's no reason to
dislike her so much so i'm just like
leah is coming on
really strong it's making me think like
what happened off camera like how do you
know leah
how do you know heather like what's
going on here because like to have so
much energy and to test for someone who
literally hasn't said anything about you
who you i think don't even know yeah
it's bizarre so she's just giving me
like police woman vibes that's how i
felt
too but i still really likely i was just
like not understanding where she's
coming
from yeah and obviously the big tadaa
with sonya morgan getting like so [ __ ]
up and like
honestly it was funny like we're working
with so little here like and i never
thought i would say this but this is
like just kind of
the cycle of housewives it's like you
hate a housewife so much because like
their behavior is atrocious and then
when they leave like it is kind of
boring and it's like
even though i did not like like or
appreciate most of what brenda brought
to the table like i'm bored without her
like i really
am so the craziest thing is like sonia
got drunk like who cares
no i i have even when you said like
someone left because of their behavior
i forgot who you were talking about and
now i realize you were talking about
during that i don't miss her for one
second they should have brought in
more new cast members 100 because five
just isn't enough we should have had
they should have brought in one more new
person
and an old person which i think heather
was meant to be
but i think that her and leah in this
particular weekend in the hamptons
get into it really bad and heather
leaves like so she doesn't film the rest
of the season
right so that's what i back down to five
and ebony is great but she's just like a
little
boring yeah so just her being the sole
focus of all the new energy i don't
think it's enough
i agree i totally agree with that but um
she was the only one
dressed right for the day okay so it was
beyond stunning when ramona was being
the fashion police
to liam mcsweeney ramona needed to
arrest herself with that
big [ __ ] knee-length vest yeah she
took it off and she changed
um lee looked great they looked like i
was just cool and different like i would
not wear that outfit
but i appreciate it for lea like i like
that she has a sense of style that it's
different from yeah someone would wear
that top with black jeans or
those pants with a black top like
because that's but like her outfit at
sonia's garden like she does it in
leah's way she does it in her own way
and it's like
and she cares what leah is wearing like
she also looks amazing and everything so
it really doesn't it's actually unfair
yeah um so yeah it was like a fine
episode um jersey's on tonight the
not the finale part two of the reunion
yeah i didn't watch part one yet so
we'll just recap no part one of the
arena
finale was last week i didn't watch a
finale okay because i was uh oh we were
in nashville so two episodes we'll recap
that tomorrow yeah anything else on
tonight
beverly hills no way
no way hills that's
i saw a club like a sneak peek and it's
lunch or dinner with garcelle and lisa
arena and garcelle is like
holding lisa lisa arena to the fire for
what she did to denise
and lisa rayne is like i shouldn't have
been so hard on denise but it's like
where is that energy lap bring danny's
back
justice for [ __ ] denise bring denise
i love garcelle for being such a good
friend like even though denise is off
the show
still bringing it up getting
accountability yeah
but rena is just like a political animal
and she will say
now that denise is gone she'll say it
doesn't matter what she says now she did
what she needs over here so she just
yeah i can't wait wow what a good night
i was gonna go out to dinner but i think
i shouldn't no i think you need to stay
in for this one me too ordering a pizza
it's such a traumatic like such a first
world problem
with my dinner last night but like when
you're when you're so hungry and your
food is just not coming like i don't
think there's anything worse like
me and ben order from a sushi place they
have two locations and ben insisted that
we order not from the one two blocks
away but from the one thirty blocks away
because he thinks it's better he was
just being a baby and i was like okay
fine whatever
so the food gets prepared and the
courier picks it up and the courier's on
foot
so i feel so bad i'm making this guy
walk 30 blocks because ben
prefers it was such a mess it took two
hours to get my food it was freezing
cold and i was like so mad so
i just like i'm not gonna ever let my
dinner get out of hand like that again
no that's good
i'm ordering for myself ben you can
order whatever like [ __ ]
order from brooklyn for all i care like
i'm taken care of you gotta look out for
yourself nobody's looking out for you
nobody's looking out for you
i was so upset i'm so sorry um let's
dive into your toasters before our
interview with remy bader and dear
toasters is brought to you by noom
think about everything you've ever
learned about getting healthy there's a
lot of contradictory information out
there and things like that old-fashioned
food pyramid
pyramid aren't much help enter new you
know how to chew you know how to use
chopsticks how to fold a slice of pizza
so the cheese doesn't slide off
but do you really know how to eat noom
says if you want to lose weight it's
about
it's not about one thing you ate today
but how you eat in general
so it's not about what you just ate but
how you eat in general noom teaches you
about eating your cravings
how to build new habits so you can ditch
the old misconceptions against smart
about food and the choices you make
based in psychology noom teaches you how
to eat so you can accomplish your
personal health goals
and stick with them long term because
you don't need rules to lose weight you
need knowledge
and with nume you pick the health goals
that are right for you and noon
personalizes a weight loss program
to help your aspirations become reality
because sometimes it's not about the
scale i know for me it's like always
about how i feel like i get fatigued
when i'm not eating really well
i get headaches so everyone has their
own reasons for wanting to get in shape
or start eating better
and noom is a solution for anyone no
matter what your goal is yeah and
especially if you're rising and grinding
like noom is your friend
and what i love about noom is noom
doesn't judge like you can be rising or
grinding and of course you feel like
okay yes i want i'm so excited to tell
you about everything that i did right
but you know what even when you're not
nume doesn't judge they understand that
life happens they'll teach you
perfect they'll teach you why you make
the choices you do and give you the
tools to replace your habits with
healthier ones
there's assigns to getting healthier and
it's called noom sign up for your trial
today at noon
n o o m dot com slash
toast learn how to eat again with nume
sign up for your trial today at noon.com
toast are you ready to learn how to live
healthier sign up for noom today at
noomnoom.com
toast love it all right dear toasters
hi jackie and claudia i recently got
engaged to my fiance who happens to be
100 italian
which has tremendous perks an abundance
of meat sauce homemade cookies around
all the time et cetera et cetera
unfortunately it also comes with major
drums a few months before getting
engaged my sister-in-law meadow and my
mother-in-law
carmela oh these are from the serranos
okay
i'm like that's a weird like mostly
people just choose like sarah no
yeah yeah meadow my sister-in-law meadow
and mother-in-law carmella stopped
speaking
this has been building for years as
carmela loathes me
meadow's husband hello this husband and
it has now been about six months of them
not speaking at all
meadow has three kids that carmela and
tony have not been able to see in six
long months
this is put my fiance and i smack dab in
the middle of this drama
we are still speaking to both sides but
carmella feels very strongly that we
should not invite meadow and her husband
to our intimate wedding destination
destination wedding of 20 people in
march
meanwhile meadow has not asked one
detail about our wedding i know i have
to invite her but is it completely
selfish that i don't want her at the
wedding
do i have to invite her husband that the
entire family despises
frankly i don't want to have to deal
with any of this drama on my wedding day
sincerely yours a toaster that belongs
on hbo
um i need to know why they hate the
husband like is it just like personality
stuff or is he like a really bad person
um
for actual reasons that you can listen
right if it's just like dumb family
drama that
people are taking really seriously i
would say invite them because things
like this change all the time you don't
want to like look back
on your wedding photos and like not be
able to include your brother and
sister-in-law who like you're now you
know 10 years in the future
close with yeah weddings are just one of
those things weddings and funerals like
you just go yeah because drama comes and
goes unless it's like an unforgivable
offense
right exactly but it's like if they wind
up
reconciling and then you just like are
on the outs still even though this
wasn't your fight i would just invite
them
they probably won't even come and unless
there's something like really terrible
that's been done
i i just think it's family and you guys
are all in this together
there's a line and if they haven't
crossed it yet you have to invite them
yeah
all right next up hi claudia and jackie
i absolutely love listening to the
morning shows every morning
it's one of the few things that truly
brighten up my morning i really felt
compelled to share my current situation
with you guys because i need to know
that i'm not crazy
last weekend while celebrating mother's
day with my boyfriend's family his older
brother luke told me that
someone in our small town found a
website full of naked pictures of some
of my best friends
i immediately shared the link with my
friends alerting them that this was
happening apparently this was old news
because my friend's phone got hacked two
years ago and she's been fighting and
failing to get them taken down
because she's over the age of 18. she
asked me to tell her as much
wait she asked me to tell her as much as
possible about who resurfaced these and
how i even got them so i explained that
luke's friend carter received them from
another group chat and shared them with
this group chat of 12 people
she was shocked to find this out because
carter was apparently her friend
so she reached out politely to tell him
that she was disappointed he didn't come
to her first
rather than share it with 12 other boys
carter proceeded to get angry with his
group chat which caused luke to get
angry with me for telling her it was
carter
oh and it get what gets worse my
boyfriend's parents and sister then
involved themselves
so i had four four of his family members
yelling at me telling me i was wrong to
tell my best friend who shared the
pictures
i was speechless disgusted and outraged
why the hell do i care if carter gets in
trouble
shouldn't these parents know that people
need to be held accountable for sharing
private pictures without consent
am i in the wrong here i need to know
what's standing up for my friend that
standing up for my friend was the right
thing to do it was
i have to say that my boyfriend
immediately immediately apologized on
their behalf and tried to get them to
understand my side
how am i supposed to feel comfortable
around these people again please help an
rdh toaster
girl you did nothing wrong like i keep
thinking if i was one of those girls
whose phone got hacked
photos illegally stolen and can't get
them taken down because i'm over 18 like
that's so disgusting
who cares who's circulating it like
there's justice on the table and that's
what counts
that's what counts so at least your
boyfriend like knows what's up because
otherwise i was about to say oh he's
only your boyfriend bye
and then with the family like they've
they've shown you who you are and now
it's just
arm's length time yeah like i that's
actually really disappointing because
at the end of the day we should all be
concerned for like this girl's group of
friends who are being so
violated and like everyone's circulating
it around making it so much worse
and the fact that all we care about is
[ __ ] carter who [ __ ] cares about
carter [ __ ] carter
i'm not finding carter [ __ ] carter [ __ ]
carter so you totally did the right
thing you can sleep at night knowing
that like you're a good friend and a
good person and like a good
woman you're actually the definition of
a woman who supports other women hundred
percent and your mother-in-law is not or
future mother-in-law
yeah so now you know the more the more
you know and that your boyfriend knows
what's up is really all you can ask for
in the situation i'm just like
i'm so sorry for your friends i know but
i'm actually really relieved to hear
that your boyfriend
is also like a woman who supports other
women or a man who supports other women
i mean
yeah phew all right finally hi claudia
and jackie
my fiance and i are getting married next
fall i already asked all my bridesmaids
to be in the wedding
party my fiance has yet to ask his
groom's been but he's always planned to
ask his dad to be his best man
let me start by saying i have no problem
with this his dad is truly his best
friend and i think it's super cute that
he would ask
him his brother is absolutely nuts
that's a story for another time
and he would feel bad choosing a friend
over his brother so his dad just seems
like the best choice
i agree so the only problem with it is
that i don't necessarily want him in all
the bridal party photos
he's already gonna be in the family
photos obviously so i just feel like
that's a lot
number one he's gonna be exhausted he's
an older man in his mid 60s
he's not in great shape and i feel like
him running around for hours would take
a lot of his energy
and the wedding one wouldn't have even
wait and the wedding won't have even
started by then
and then of course reason number two is
i feel like he would stick out like a
sore thumb
i don't want my eyes to draw to him
every time i look at my bridal party
photos
wow just typing that i feel like a huge
[ __ ] but i can't help that i feel that
way
yikes my fiancee gets very mad every
time i bring it up and says he would
feel horrible telling his dad
he's the best man but can't be in the
bridal party pics which i understand as
well
what do i do am i just a raging
nefarious [ __ ] that needs to get over
herself
or do you agree we can ask him to step
out of some of the photos
i have a major pit about it and i don't
want his pee job dad to hate me
how do you think my fiance should bring
it up with his dad if you think he
should
is it really mean to ask him to be his
best man and then add stipulations
help a beautiful stunning and smart
bride okay so i have a plan for you
because you can't ask someone to get out
of a photo like when the photo's being
taken you're like okay now one without
you so we can have one hanging on the
wall so rude
but what you can do being that this is
your wedding and there's a lot of
planning that goes into it is you can
schedule
pictures throughout the day don't have
the adult
the or the older people come in till
later in the day because they need their
energy so like
do all the family photos last and
earlier in the day
do the bridesmaids grooming pictures
where he's not
he doesn't even know that that's
happening and then later in the day when
he is there
then do another picture with all the
groomsmen because the kid the young
people your friends can they stand
around and wait all day for the pictures
to be taken
older people don't have as much stamina
so i think you do one set of photos in
the morning
before he's expected to arrive and then
one set of photos with him
when it's his time that's possible but i
actually
and i think that's good advice but like
i don't really agree with this like
i don't know like i think you should
just be proud of the fact your husband
sounds like such a p-jump his dad is his
best man like
you obviously married like such a family
oriented like i'm gonna cry it's so
sweet like
and you want to hide that like it's so
[ __ ] up like i don't think you're
gonna be standing there in a big
poofy white dress no one's looking at
your
father-in-law like it's not going to be
this sore thumb situation
i think it's true and also like it is
like that is what's happening like
that's the truth you know yeah no and i
just think it's like leaning into it
it's really sweet
i've never heard of anyone choosing
their dad as their best man it speaks to
the kind of character of your future
husband
and i don't think you should be ashamed
of it i think like you are being a
little
[ __ ] like i do so i think that's my
advice but it's really sweet i think
it's
so special and i would lean into it it's
nice and no one is going to be looking
there's a big bride poofy dress no one
is looking at the groomsmen in the back
who's slightly older than the other
people
i agree with you but i will also say
like your wedding day is your time to be
a little [ __ ] and if this is gonna
bother you
forever for whatever maybe there's other
reasons at play
then i think you can do it in a way
without hurting anyone's feelings and
without taking the picture and then say
okay now one without you
jackie's given the road map to how you
want to do it if you want to go about
that way
my advice would be like it's actually
really sweet and
make peace with it within yourself make
peace within yourself i think it would
make him so happy
make your husband happy and your husband
obviously doesn't agree with you so like
just is this a battle you want to pick
if so go jackie's way
if not i would just let it go yeah
yeah i hear what i hear what you're
saying i hear what you're saying too of
course but it's like people have their
stuff i don't know
people have their stuff that's true just
decide whether this is a hill you want
to die on
and you die on it yeah um all right well
that is
pretty much our show except we've got an
interview coming up with remy bader if
you're listening on the oh also that was
your toasters if you ever want to write
in we're running low so dear toasters at
gmail.com
make it interesting we're going to be
slow because we're solving all the
world's problems
and that's just our cross to bear but
it's your toaster that you don't get to
a place
or at least updates if we've written to
you let us know how it went
we love updates to your toasters at
gmail.com enjoy this interview with remy
bader she was a precious gem of a woman
um podcast just keep listening youtube
it is up on our channel
and that's our show thank you so much
for listening to the morning toast the
millennium morning show where we deliver
the past life stories that you need to
know every monday through friday on
youtube so if you're watching us on
youtube
please feel free to subscribe and give
this video a thumbs up we're also
available to podcast anywhere podcasts
can be found so it's spotify itunes
stitcher public radio i got radio catbox
all the places so wherever you listen to
podcasts find us the morning church
leave a five star review about how
beautiful
and smart we are hope you have an
amazing hump day and we'll see you
tomorrow enjoy this interview with remy
vader
bye bye
you